thank you to brilliant for sponsoring
this video
this is the earth our atmosphere is a
thin layer of gas that keeps us safe
from harmful solar radiation
keeps us warm at night with its
insulating properties and transports
heat
and moisture around the planet in this
visualization
using data from the gfdl earth system
model the atmosphere has been exploded
to approximately 30 times its actual
height doing so we can see the structure
of the atmosphere
much more clearly we can see the jet
streams in each hemisphere
narrow bands are fast moving air in the
mid latitudes
higher up we can see the stratospheric
polar vortex spinning over the
wintertime pole in the upper atmosphere
we can also see that the earth is
wreathed in clouds
at any one time about 67 percent of the
earth's surface
is obscured by clouds and these have a
huge effect on the earth's climate
they cool the earth by reflecting
sunlight away from its surface
stopping solar energy from warming the
land or ocean underneath
clouds are obviously formed by water
evaporating from the oceans into the
atmosphere and the warmer the oceans are
the more evaporation takes place
therefore you would expect that if the
earth were to warm
more clouds would form and these clouds
would then
act to cool the earth acting as a
moderating influence
pushing it back to its original cooler
temperature
let's test this dialing in some global
warming
we start to see more clouds so far so
good
but something unusual is happening the
cloud coverage of the earth is increased
but the planet is continuing to warm
what's going on aren't the clouds
reflecting more solar energy away from
the earth shouldn't the earth be
cooling instead well by warming the
earth we've increased the rate of
evaporation from the oceans
this results in more clouds but it also
results in
an invisible change in the atmosphere as
well as more clouds
it now contains more water vapour
to explain what the difference is
between those two things
here's fellow atmospheric physicist and
oxford grad dr adam levy
who you might already know from their
excellent youtube channel
climate adam water vapor is well it's
kind of what it says it is
water in its vapor form so the water
that we drink
is a liquid and water vapor is a gas
it floats around mixed in with all the
other gases and all in all makes up a
couple of percent of earth's atmosphere
though that depends whether we're
talking about the atmosphere above an
ocean or the atmosphere above a desert
clouds on the other hand
are not gaseous they're actually liquid
or
solid that might sound ridiculous since
they're floating in the air
but a cloud is actually made up of loads
of tiny water droplets
or in the case of an ice cloud ice
crystals
because they're a different state of
matter they actually have
very different climate properties than
water vapor
one of the most important subjects in
climate science
is feedbacks positive and negative
feedbacks to be precise
now positive and negative feedback might
sound like the description for any
youtube comment section
but that's not exactly what climate
scientists mean by it
when we talk about feedbacks we mean a
positive feedback
is something that amplifies any global
temperature changes that are going on
and a negative feedback is something
that dampens those changes
water vapor acts as a positive feedback
boosting global warming that's because
water in its gaseous form
is actually a greenhouse gas it may be
invisible to the naked eye
but it absorbs the infrared radiation
that the earth gives off
so if something heats the planet up that
increases the amount of water vapor in
the atmosphere
and that heats things up even more
a positive feedback a crucial question
is how
all the different feedbacks interact and
what the total effect will be
in other words what the total global
warming will be
one way to get at an answer is to use
climate models like the one simon's been
showing you
of course all models including the one
simon's been showing you
are imperfect in other words they have
biases
so climate scientists use lots of
different models all of which simulate
the climate in slightly different ways
and some have slightly different biases
the hope is that by taking the average
across all these models you get a more
trustworthy answer for how
big the feedbacks will be and so how hot
the world will get any increase in the
temperature of the earth is accompanied
by
various feedbacks some positive some
negative
the climate model that generated this
data accounts for many of these
feedbacks but
can't account for all of them the
system's just too complicated
the largest feedbacks such as the
increase in the earth's reflectivity due
to an increase in clouds
is accounted for as is the increased
insulation provided by a higher
percentage of water vapor in the
atmosphere
the fact is though that any model is
just a representation of
reality in statistical modelling there's
a saying
all models are wrong but some are useful
this model is useful to us and that can
be verified by comparing it to real
climate observations it's not perfect
sure but it does a pretty good
job of representing reality with that
said
there's one more thing to still explain
how exactly did we produce the warming
in this model this model was warmed as
part of a standard experiment performed
to test different climate models
quadrupling the concentration of carbon
dioxide
in the atmosphere this increase in co2
produced warming all on its own
as the gas efficiently stops heat from
leaving the earth
causing it to build up in the atmosphere
and thus the average temperature to
increase
this is exactly what we humans are doing
by emitting so much carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere
however as we saw after this initial
warming had taken place
the temperature of the planet continued
to rise despite its
increased cloud cover this was because
of the positive feedback from water
vapor
overwhelming the other feedbacks this
means that water vapor
amplifies any warming in the system that
we humans produce by emitting greenhouse
gases
like carbon dioxide it does this so much
that in fact
water vapor is the most significant
greenhouse gas of all
responsible for around 50 of all
anthropogenic global warming
co2 by comparison only contributes
around 20
we know that water vapor is boosting the
global warming that we're causing
but it seems that cloud cover is more
complex than first
meets the eye potentially also acting as
a positive feedback
in a collab over my channel we discuss
why water
in both vapor and clouds is crucial to
understanding climate change
but why carbon dioxide is still the
culprit
and the thing we need to cut simon
helped me out
and i even got him to sing although it
didn't take much convincing
this planet is beautiful in its
complexity
that complexity is visible in the
pattern of winds across its surface
and in its response to changes in the
atmosphere
the net result of that complexity is
somewhat uncertain
but it certainly seems that the net
influence of water
in vapor and in clouds is to amplify
what we humans do
the visualization in this video was made
by me from scratch and doing so required
several key skills
firstly knowing how to navigate the data
structures climate scientists use
secondly writing a python script to pull
the data from those structures and put
it into blender
and lastly a surprising amount of
trigonometry to make the clouds work
if you'd like to make something similar
then you can improve all of these skills
with
brilliant an educational website an app
that focuses on learning by
doing it's simple you just pick one of
their expertly written
wonderfully illustrated interactive
courses that interests you
and you get stuck in try solving some
problems and if you get them wrong
that's okay brilliant is all about
learning from your mistakes and making
sure that you know it's okay to make
them
they have courses on every aspect of the
workflow of this video
from abstract computer science to
programming with python to trigonometry
quite apart from their courses on the
radiative physics discussed in this
video
brilliant is perfect to supplement your
learning in the classroom if you're a
student
or expanding your skills if you're out
in the big wide world of employment
to get a sweet 20 discount on an annual
subscription go to brilliant.org
simon clark but be quick only the first
200 people to click the link in the
description will get this great deal
invest in yourself and get learning
brilliantly
thanks to brilliant for their continued
support of this channel
thank you so much to adam for taking
part in this video if you haven't
checked out their youtube channel before
definitely do they make really good
videos about all
aspects of climate science including
up-to-date research as well as
myths and misconceptions that are
commonly propagated on the internet
this visualization took quite some time
to develop and i really hope you're
going to be seeing
more of it in the future if you'd like
to see more videos like this then
definitely hit the subscribe button and
if you enjoyed this video please do pop
it a like
thank you again for watching and i'll
see you in the next one